protests riots and looted for the first
time in my entire life the whole nation
is on the same page about a disgusting
act of police brutality yet we're
completely divided about how to protest
Tucker Carlson the human charcuterie
board denounced the riots and protests
suggesting a Trump should come down
harder on the unrest and then Michael
Moore also known as drag Rosie O'Donnell
then by drag I mean behind a boat
supported the riots and was glad the
evil police precinct was burned down and
my favorite civil rights activist David
Guetta said so this Reagan is in honor
of George Floyd so Wow
thank you David Luther King jr. you know
what I do have a dream that you jump off
that building I mean pick an accent you
sound like Bruno [__] borock now I know
what you're thinking but Andrew it's not
the peaceful protesters those people are
great people marching with their kids
staying away from my white neighborhood
holding signs dance with cops posting
black squares on Instagram not that one
the peaceful protests are amazing I just
can't stand for the riots and looting I
hear your point and we'll get to riots
in a second but let's start with looting
looting is breaking into stores and
stealing the contents and this is
unequivocally wrong these people are
using the riots as a smoke screen in
order to personally benefit from this
tragedy they're salty people and it
affects small businesses way more it's
selfish it's [__] up these protests
are for justice so explain to me how you
solve systemic racism with a cheesecake
also white people why the [__] are you
looting I understand we like stealing
[__] obviously that's how black people
got here but this is not the time and
don't pretend you're not doing it a van
store got robbed that's white people's
timberlands and if anybody got the black
and white checkers in a size 13 DME also
influencers if you're posting pics of
yourself pretending to board up stores
you're looting sure we know it's staged
women can't use a drill but still you're
enriching yourself off a tragedy I mean
last week cops arrested Jake Paul while
exploited black struggle and I don't
mean his rap career also if you're a
news outlet that hand selects clips to
fit your networks biased narrative
you're looting and if you're a handsome
comedian with a great smile and ears
like Dobby and you're talking about this
event
that's not looting I just can't get on
stage because Chinese people keep eating
bats so we agree the peaceful protests
are good and the looting is bad now
let's talk about the gray area in
between
riding riding is not peaceful it is the
intentional destruction of property for
the sake of sending a message and by
that definition it seems wrong I
wouldn't want someone smashing my
windows and frankly we want to see cop
cars on fire and I know what you're
thinking
why can't they just protest peacefully
and the answer is they did they
protested after Terrence croucher was
killed but the cops are still acquitted
they protest after Samuel DuBose was
killed but the case was dismissed and if
you've never heard of those people it's
because they're peaceful protests never
reach you so ask yourself if you
exhausted every option of peaceful
protest for decades and the prosecution
of police still hasn't changed what
would you do what options do you have
left how long would you go on being
ignored while the people swore to
protect you
gunned down your neighbors without due
process one year ten years 400 years you
complained about your rights being
stripped when Corona kept you in your
house for a month
I do think getting uh-oh talking about
at least protests I think something
really positive is gonna come out of
this because the fact that somebody
white people are also Pro and getting
involved in it and so many cops were
vocal saying you know they shouldn't do
that so I think something good is going
to come out of this I just agree more
I really did I do and I hope so too
because it's it it's been wrong for way
too long
and I also hope that that a bunch of
other groups don't use this as a
piggyback thing to then do some other
[__] which will then escalate will make
people who want things to stay the same
they'll be able to shift focus of like
you know like how they try to make like
the protesters and the riot or like the
looters the same people right right
where it's just yeah there's only yeah
you did that and then a night you did
this no yeah the way so yeah I don't
know what anyways I think there's the
once the looting died down you're seeing
peaceful protests that are very
encouraging I think it's great I really
do I mean that downtown LA one was
amazing fifty thousand [__] people
filled the streets and no crime or very
little nothing I heard of it was just
mostly people chanting and holding signs
they looked promising
look they kind of the the thing that
disturbs me is this idea that they
should defund the police you can't get
rid of the police what you need to do is
spend more
and train them better and I have higher
standards and do it the way you do the
military where it's very difficult to
get in and you weed people out there
weak like that guy was a [__] that guy
leaning on that guy's neck like that
that guy's a monster there's no way that
guy because he knew he was being filmed
too and he just had you know yeah I mean
that's like hands in his pockets like he
was just [__] you know waiting for an
uber or something like that makes you
think yeah he's a monster yeah and that
guy had been doing that forever you know
there's new evidence that they work
together and they fought they argued
about the way that cop was treating the
customers they work together at security
at the same club and that cop was a
[__] [__] to people at the club
and they argued about it so they had a
personal issue and there's some people
that want it to be elevated to
first-degree murder because of that that
he did it on purpose though he knew he
knew that guy I mean it's just yeah if
they argued that when they work together
apparently one of the guys that worked
with them said that George Floyd was
always telling that guy he's a [__]
[__] the way he treats customers
because he would mace people and [__]
that kind of stuff pepper spray folks he
just was the first guy to use violence
right away yes escalate this he had a
history of complaints back to 2006 if
the problem is is these looters who are
the 1% of the protesters that are
damaging every city they can find it
yeah dude all this stuff that the hair
white I'm sorry no they're not
I don't like weave good no it's not all
just right in Antigua that's not fair
that's true you're given antiva too much
credit yeah a lot of those yes the black
looters up a lot of those people are
people who are looting who you know 40
million people are unemployed yeah whoo
and then you stick well the mayor the
mayor of Atlanta said you know and and
kill him I said do you want to make a
difference keep don't burn your own
house down sign up a register go to the
census so they know who you are and
where you are yeah that's the long game
people on action now yes people want you
know the other thing is is uh you know
the looters are you know it's it's 99%
of the media coverage and I think media
is the enemy of the state you look at
the the coverage that they're posting
you know there's been way more positive
and friendly peaceful protests
there's been looters but these looters
the 1% are painting the narrative so
everyone thinks this is the you know the
world's on fire yeah the other thing is
their other positive the other positive
is that policing in 2015 they were like
weed they had a was still a problem but
they had a major problem I think
something like a hundred two unarmed
black men were killed and we know the
stories and some of the stories we don't
know about and in 2019 it was nine it's
been a better there's been a dramatic
decrease so it is like because I
diversified police forces there are a
lot more black cops and so so it there
has been progress made so you shouldn't
feel cloudy hearted
there's still work to be done if there's
progress for sure oh Jesus the summer's
here and I just feel like if a bunch of
people can get together and throw bricks
through the windows of a target I can go
to the beach okay cuz if I can't do that
isn't that like a double standard Oh big
shout-out to anybody who actually could
sit there and watch the news over the
last week and continue to watch the news
and do all of that I don't know why you
would do that to yourself it's gonna
give you a horrible idea of humanity and
what people are like I would venture to
say that 99.9% of the population is not
writing is not pulling people over and
then you know beating them up murdering
them or whatever okay but if you want to
sit there and watch the news and get all
[__] bummed out about that [__] I
mean that is that is your prerogative
and I salute you for wanting to be that
informed however I I do understand that
there's always going to be
mouth-breathers and there's always gonna
be you know misdirected anger there's
gonna be a bunch of stuff but you got to
keep your eye on the ball on this thing
okay you know I just think that there
needs to be really reality is is if we
ever want to solve this everyone would
have to get involved and everyone
have to give a [__] and I think it would
go beyond you know just tweeting black
lives matter and there I did my part
like you'd really have to like this
there's no reason to just be still doing
this to each other there's no [__]
reason for there just as there's no
reason for it
and I you know I don't know I just don't
understand how somebody can be face down
with handcuffs even though it appears
there was some sort of altercation in
the back of the cruiser there was some
sort of resisting arrest you know you
shouldn't do that they already got you
you are handcuffed or whatever but like
at some point when you're faced out and
you know handcuffs saying I can't
breathe I just don't understand and I'm
ignorant of the whole process I don't
understand why you can't just ease up
your knee maybe move your knee off of
the neck you could still be I mean I
don't know what sort of human being with
their arms behind their back can do you
know was he worried that the guy was
gonna start doing the worm and [__]
flip him off and then I don't know break
his handcuffs I don't know what deal was
but when somebody says they can't
breathe
and the unprecedent amount of leaders
that are just saying insightful things
is just unbelievable like if you can say
I can't breathe that means you can
breathe and it's just like buddy if that
was your daughter or your son or you
would you really have that same
perspective you know what I mean there's
different levels of not being able to
breathe it's not getting a full breath
okay that would be like if a [__]
Python grabbed you and started to
squeeze you and you're like dude help me
out help me up breathe I mean it's so
and even though that dude was from
Mississippi I'm not judging everybody
down there in Mississippi I'm sure
there's plenty of people that can kind
of see this thing so hopefully you know
I think the curfews are a great thing
that'll stop the mouth-breathing morons
from
attacking small businesses for whatever
[__] reason you know I would think if
there was some sort of like through line
to the outrage you would go after major
corporations rather than mom-and-pop
stores I don't know why people would do
that but anyway and then the white
people also looting going down they're
like it's Spring Break like hey let's
[__] act like we're oppressed see
what this feels like I don't understand
that either and it's all just so the
whole thing is [__] weird but it's
the still the focus is that there and it
was so great to see so many police
officers saying that that that situation
Minneapolis was not handled correctly
that is unprecedented you know there's
always been everybody just the cops
always just stayed with each other and
it's time like to correct that problem
and I think it's time to hear from both
sides because also being a cop every
night you could get killed and you're
going up to a vehicle you have no
[__] idea
what the person is gonna do you can't
see their [__] hands you don't know
what's going on and who wants to die
nobody I mean it's a it's an incredibly
difficult job I would think so I think
there needs to be some empathy you need
to listen and all of these people you
know who are just Fanning the flames I
just don't understand unless you enjoy
it you just [__] have hate in your
heart or something I don't understand
what this is and you know I don't know I
don't know but I would not judge people
by these idiots at night doing what
they're doing I understand some of the
rage and that type of stuff but I just
go into somebody's mom-and-pop store and
just [__] burning it down and taking
all their [__] like I don't know that
just seems like that's just sort of a
that's not a smart move all right there
I said it
okay as I said my little [__] piece
what do i any know what I'm gonna do now
I'm gonna get back to my [__]